hey crazies is the Multiverse actually
possible given the success of everything
everywhere all at once it's certainly a
popular storytelling tool right now
but physics has a lot to say about
multiverses and these stories only tend
to focus on one kind and there are three
[Music]
I've invented a machine to help us out
with this whole Multiverse thing but I'm
no engineer so it's a bit delicate we're
gonna need to be careful what's this
thing no no don't touch the Multiverse
is not a new invention the idea has been
around for thousands of years early
versions were just cyclical these many
universes didn't exist at the same time
they were more like one Universe caught
in a repeating series of creation and
destruction then again maybe you don't
think anything like that should be
called a Multiverse well somewhere
around 2000 years ago we started to see
a change in thought according to the
ancient Greeks it is in the highest
degree unlikely that the Earth and Sky
is the only one to have been created and
that all particles of matter outside are
accomplishing nothing and of course we
all know the ancient Greeks were the
pioneers of human philosophy yeah no the
ancient Indians had similar writings who
will search through the wide Infinities
of space to count the universes side by
side we don't know exactly when
statements like these were written
because history is full of fairy tales
and ancient history is sparse but we do
know this idea stuck around it's
something philosophers Now call Cosmic
pluralism though for a while this
concept was intertwined with religion in
1584 former Dominican Friar Giordano
Bruno would famously say he is glorified
not in one but in countless Sons not in
a single Earth a single world but in a
thousand thousand I say in an Infinity
of Worlds the he in that statement is
the Christian God as you can imagine
this idea wasn't very popular in the
Roman Catholic Church things did not end
well for Giordano Bruno
are we back
I think we're back
where was I right the Multiverse the
actual word Multiverse wouldn't enter
scientific conversation until about 1896
in a debate between Ludwig boltzmann and
Ernst cermello they weren't actually
discussing cosmology though
they were trying to decide if
statistical mechanics was sufficient to
describe the laws of thermodynamics of
course any conversation about entropy
quickly grows to Cosmic proportions pun
intended anyway we have two models on
the front line of physics general
relativity and quantum mechanics and
both of them have something to say about
the Multiverse
when you hear the term Multiverse you
probably think of one particular example
and it has to do with people's choices
say you're I I don't know trying to
decide which flooring to put in your
house your partner wants easy to clean
hardwood while you want that glorious
soft carpet eventually you decide on the
carpet because you're not a monster but
what if there was another version of you
that decided on the hardwood instead
what if that decision split the universe
in two in one reality your house has
carpet in the other there's hardwood
this exact concept has led to some
fantastic stories in my lifetime
everything everywhere all at once is
just the latest iteration before that
there was the Marvel Cinematic
Multiverse before that there were the
two universes in Fringe before that
there was the quantum mirror in Stargate
before that there was Star Trek the Next
Generation where Warf was married to
Troy for a hot minute but the writers
abandoned it almost immediately stupid
writers
are you done yeah I guessed
before Wharf and Troy there was the
infamous Mirror Universe from the
original series in the late 1960s my
point is this Trope has been around
probably as long as the hypothesis has
been around so let's take a look at
where that comes from oh no not again
this idea that our choices split the
universe in two comes from quantum
mechanics
Schrodinger's equation says wave
functions evolve deterministically over
time but our observations show this
isn't always true
say a photon's wave function passes
through both of these slits as the
photon moves forward it will be in a
superposition of many locations
determined by the interference pattern
of the waves from each slit however when
it reaches the screen we'll only see it
at a single location the wave nature of
the photon is gone we call this wave
function collapse and it happens
suddenly and randomly in stark contrast
to the smooth Behavior described by
Schrodinger's equation wave function
collapse was problematic to say the
least but it was unavoidable that is
until 1957 when a physicist named Hugh
Everett proposed the many worlds
hypothesis he asked a simple question
what if the wave function never
collapses what if the screen just
becomes correlated with the wave
function all possible locations for the
photon could still exist just in
different universes at the time Hugh
Everett suggested his many worlds
interpretation Nation it seemed extreme
it was controversial and it had a share
of problems what was keeping observers
in each of these worlds from being aware
of the others these problems wouldn't be
solved until 1970 when a type of
censorship was discovered We Now call
decoherence
make it stop
okay so honestly the many worlds
interpretation could be a whole video
all by itself but you're not here for
the gruesome details here's what you
actually need to know one these Quantum
realities are not some vast distance
away they overlap at the same location
your house with carpet occupies the same
space as your house with hardwood they
just don't interact so you're completely
unaware of each other it's not actually
as crazy as it sounds consider these two
waves traveling toward each other along
a string they won't Collide instead
they'll combine into one composite wave
for a Time eventually they'll pass
through each other entirely and return
to their original shape as if the other
one wasn't even there the same thing
happens with waves on the surface of a
pond
Schrodinger's equation is what describes
the quantum world and its Solutions are
waves so it's it's not that crazy to
think the quantum world might behave
this way each Universe being a different
Ripple in some four-dimensional pond
two this is not about human choices
well I mean sure if you subscribe to the
many worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics your choices would be
splitting universes but that doesn't
make you special this splitting would be
happening for every Quantum interaction
that releases information to the
environment your brain just happens to
also be made of quantum particles three
it's not the entire universe dividing
this is a local event
a superposition just splits into
measurable States at that location that
separation happens here and only here
the rest of the universe is fine all the
information is still there too you just
can't see the whole thing anymore and
finally four this isn't like a tree that
branches continuously and gets larger
over time other Quantum events might
bring them back together so it's not
necessarily permanent it's more like a
big messy web of events than a tree full
of universes fictional stories like
everything everywhere all at once can be
fun but they're not real it's important
to look at the science behind these
things too
we've figured out over the last century
that the Universe has been around for
about 13.8 billion years and is
currently 93 billion light years across
but that's just the observable universe
we know the whole thing is at least 20
times larger than that but it's probably
infinite and our finite part is really
uniform sure on the smaller scale you've
got interesting collections like planets
stars and galaxies but if the smallest
piece you look at is about a hundred
million light years across the
observable universe is basically the
same everywhere there's no reason to
think that's gonna suddenly change
beyond the observable Edge so oh come on
I just got into a rhythm today we're
going to be estimating how many
universes there are can you actually
calculate that uh yeah I mean well we
can do a very crude estimate
okay so let's let's let's take a look
our observable universe
has a finite size let's say this is our
observable universe
it is 10 to the 27 meters across there's
a lot it's a lot of meters but it is
finite as far as we can tell this
observable universe is inside of a
larger space that is infinite in size
probably we don't know that for sure but
all of our data suggests that it is
infinite
now if our observable universe has a
finite size with a finite number of
particles in it and if those particles
can have a finite number of
configurations which stands to reason if
the observable universe is finite then
in an infinite space those patterns
should repeat eventually we'd expect
them to repeat
and so the next natural question here is
how many particles are in the universe
now that's something we call eddington's
number and it's an estimate we've had
for a while it is
10 to the 80 there are 10 to the 80
protons in the observable universe but
are there particles other than protons
there are neutrons and electrons but
those don't actually affect this
estimate all that much
see most of the matter in the universe
is inside of stars it's mostly hydrogen
or ionized hydrogen which is just
protons
neutrons don't show up until you make
larger elements on the periodic table
and so
uh there aren't nearly as many of them
but even if there were even if there
were exactly the same number of neutrons
in exactly the same number of electrons
you would just end up with 3 times 10 to
the 80.
which in this case and the way we're
doing these estimates that's still just
10 to the 80 that would round down to 10
to the 80. we're doing very very
aggressive estimations here something we
call order of magnitude estimation so
we're only interested in the powers of
10.
something else we know is we know the
diameter of a proton so this thing has a
diameter it does take up some space
because it's made of smaller particles
and this size is something we call one
femtometer which is 10 to the negative
15 meters it's a very small amount of
space but again it is a finite space if
we want to know how many possible spaces
they could exist in we need to know how
many we could cram in there like to the
brim we want to cram it full of protons
how many protons would there be and
that's actually not that difficult of a
calculation so all we have to do
is divide the two sizes
10 to the 27 the diameter of the
universe
and divide it by the diameter of a
proton
and we get something like this now this
will tell us how many protons we could
fit along the diameter of the observable
universe but what we want is the entire
volume and so all we have to do
is cubit
now sure you might want to put like a
four-thirds pie out front or something
but again that's a fraction or a number
outside of the power of 10 and so it
doesn't actually matter we don't
actually need to know the four thirds Pi
for a spherical volume it does all we
need is the powers of 10. this fraction
cubed comes out to be 10 to the 126
spaces and so this is how many spaces
are available for protons to exist in
in order to figure out how many
different configurations these protons
can have again we're doing rough
estimates we're not going to worry too
much about how they collected atoms or
anything
or to put this another way we want to
choose 10 to the 80 out of 10 to the 126
and that's very specific language it's
called combinatorics
to get our final crude estimate we need
three things the formula for
combinations Sterling's approximation
which is a way to find factorials of
large numbers more easily and the fact
that 10 to the 126 is much larger than
10 to the 80. when all is said and done
we get a formula that's very simple now
all we have to do is plug in the numbers
so assuming space is infinite we get
approximately 10 to the 10 to the 82
unique universes unique verses
anyway this is a stupid big number and
believe it or not this is the easiest
Multiverse to understand these universes
aren't in some other plane of existence
they're just a ridiculous distance away
if the expansion of space wasn't
accelerating we could actually reach
them if we were patient enough
it's just a numbers game but that
expansion of space comment has me
thinking
there was this era in the early Universe
called Cosmic inflation where space was
expanding at a rate
oh crap hey science Asylum Nick here
what is the fastest thing your first
thought might be a cheetah which can
reach speeds up to 59 miles per hour
Usain Bolt is the fastest human and his
highest recorded speed is only about 27
miles per hour
slow poke
but that's not the fastest humans have
ever gone according to the Guinness Book
of World Records the fastest speed
humans have ever traveled is 24 800
miles per hour aboard the command module
for Apollo 10. if you know a little
physics though you know the universal
limit is the speed of light
travels at 670 million miles per hour in
a vacuum so that settles it light is the
fastest thing
or is it the endless chain of cause and
effect puts an upper limit on how fast
things can move in space but it puts no
such limit on how fast space itself can
move
the space contained within the universe
has been expanding since the beginning
but not always at the same rate
right now at this very moment most
galaxies are moving away from us faster
than light because the space between us
is expanding faster than light
however shortly after the big bang it
temporarily expanded exponentially
faster it had to otherwise the universe
would not have been as uniform as it is
today
this begs the question why did this
period of cosmic inflation stop
but that begs an even better question
did it stop
remember some infinities are larger than
others there could easily be an infinite
space inside of an even larger Infinite
Space
Cosmic inflation began when the
observable universe was a trillion times
smaller than an atom it occurred shortly
after the big bang it lasted only for a
decillionth of a second that's a
billionth of a trillionth of a
trillionth of a second this period of
inflation stopped as quickly as it began
leaving the observable universe about
the size of your fist
its volume expanded by a factor of 10 to
the 78th power to expand that much again
the universe would take another 13.8
billion years we know Cosmic inflation
stopped in our observable universe
otherwise it wouldn't be here but
cosmologists soon realized something
interesting inflation doesn't have to
stop everywhere all at once our
observable universe might just be an
infinite bubble inside of an even larger
space a space experiencing inflation
eternally what implications does this
eternal inflation have that's coming up
right now foreign
okay let's try this again
infinite multiverses inside of other
infinite multiverses is going to be a
bit confusing so let's call the larger
thing in Omniverse it's a space that
contains multiverses
different multiverses within this
Omniverse are just regions where
inflation has stopped but in the voids
between those bubbles inflation is still
ongoing and no matter can exist there
that inflation is so fast that even
though a Multiverse like ours is
expanding it may never collide with
another Multiverse each Multiverse
bubble would be unreachable by the
others they would be completely separate
which gives us an extra degree of
Freedom see the many universes in our
own Multiverse may have started with a
different set of initial conditions but
all the fundamental constants are still
the same this is still the gravitational
constant this is still the fine
structure constant this is still
Planck's constant this is still the mass
of the electron every one of those
universes has the same matter in it and
it all obeys the same rules that doesn't
necessarily extend to the other
multiverses in the Omniverse
here every bubble is a separate
Multiverse each expanding at a different
rate each with a different number of
Dimensions with its own types of
particles with different kinds of
structures made from those particles our
Multiverse may be uniform but there's no
such requirement for the rest of the
Omniverse the only constant across the
Omniverse are the fundamental physical
relationships whether you think the
quantum realities from the many worlds
interpretation are real or you believe
that space itself goes on forever and
repeats or even if you think this is all
just bogus philosophy which you know
Fair opinion they might not be real but
no matter how you feel about this we
should all agree that everything is
described by two theories general
relativity and the standard model those
relationships are what hold the
Omniverse together
and until next time remember it's okay
to be a little crazy
Arthur was wondering if Brown dwarfs
could account for dark matter
what's nice is that would
no they can't the number of brown dwarfs
you would need is ridiculously larger
than could possibly exist if you want
more info I actually have a video about
this Link in the doobly-doo anyway
thanks for watching